now i don't think they heard with your
first words what did you say
i said i want to kiss you my dear that
can be a
wow ah the memories after nearly 50
years on the air the price is right
holds the title of tv's
longest running game show but like so
many hollywood productions the pandemic
shut it down in march
now network television's number one
rated daytime series is firing back up
with new safety protocols in place i
spoke with host drew carey
about some of the big changes
[Applause]
with unbridled enthusiasm and unchecked
affection
contestants have always been the stars
of the show
come on the next contestant on the
prices right
more than two million exuberant fans
have taken part in the prices right
it all starts here at cbs studios in
hollywood
where fans from across the country i am
from san antonio texas i am from buffalo
new york
line up and do whatever it takes to get
noticed
on hiatus since march because of the
pandemic the price is right is now
taping again
but doing so for the first time without
an audience
host drew carey debuted a new look is
the beard a covid creation
to be honest a lot of this stuff about
kovid if you haven't been sick
it's kind of been a little bit of a
blessing disguise to be shut down so
much because i had a lot of time
for introspection a lot of spiritual
growth
this uh this summer part of me wanted to
reflect it
with a different look so let me throw a
beard and see what it looks like and
then i
liked it when it came out and i kept it
restarting production took months of
planning the set was reconfigured to add
social distance
crew members wearing masks work in zones
safety protocols include cleaning and
testing
executive producer and showrunner evelyn
warfel says
one thing was not negotiable if you
don't hear george
say come on down at the top of the show
it's not the price is right
so i think for us the biggest challenge
was how are we going gonna do
a come on down without an audience
and we struggled with that come on down
you have the signature line there still
is the come on down
yeah yeah i haven't been backstage to
look but i've been told about it
they unhook their ears and they hold
their mask over their face
and if they hear their name they throw
the mask down and run out so they're
just as surprised
what you won't see during the pandemic
are contestants getting close to the
host bear hugs
are off limits now i remember seeing
video of you
getting knocked down by a contestant so
is this almost potentially safer now
that you have social distancing like
keeping them from you
yeah nobody's picking me up and swirling
me around but i liked
you know high-fiving people and i'd like
hugs and like
you know none of that anymore man
[Applause]
he kissed me and he needs a shave i've
got to tell you
the prices wright first aired on cbs in
1972
bob barker with his warmth and easy
going style helmed the show for 35 years
he passed the stick mic to comedian drew
carey 13 years ago
you were on in 76 76 and you won an
airplane an airplane sweetheart
an airplane we were looking for a car
needed a car real bad
and a freaking airplane comes out man
a freaking airplane in nearly half a
century
more than 250 million dollars in cash
and prizes
have been given away with a live
audience cheering non-stop
next week help this the audience free
show will premiere
with a prime time special i got a beard
not wearing a tie
and uh tonight we are saluting essential
workers
a small way for the price is right to
give back
something warfall hopes it continues to
do for the audience at home
despite the changes especially in these
times when people are really
having a difficult time they want to see
shows that
are fun and exciting and bring a little
bit of joy and happiness
host drew carey's goal is simple help
contestants
enjoy the moment i'm a host and i'm
hosting a little bit of a
smaller party than i used to so i want
everybody to be comfortable
and we love it when people win you know
everybody backstage is rooting for
people to win
never do as anybody back there going oh
we gotta save some money i hope they
lose
so the iconic game show will be airing
three prime time specials the price is
right at night featuring
frontline and essential workers is the
first one and that does air
this tuesday night at eight a couple
things i was told by the host drew carey
that it's easier to
to bid now because you don't have the
entire audience shouting stuff out a lot
of times people couldn't hear anything
then
the wheel does exist it gets sanitized
in between so we have the big wheel
and then the thought of like why
couldn't you do this virtually if people
were sitting at home
they could look the prices up and they
didn't want to have that so that's why
yeah yeah yeah it is looking good
so nice honestly so so nice really fun
to talk about i want to know what
happened to that airplane
it's on the dvr already it's one of
those shows that has been passed down to
generation degeneration that's exactly
dedication from like grandparents to
parents to kids
when you're sick